- [Voiceover] Oh no, there's the new guy.
Okay, okay, what was his
name? What was his name?
He told me when we met.
What was it? Think!
- Hey, I'm Darius. Paul. Logan.
Ben. Darren. Darren. Darren.
- [Voiceover] Darren? Yeah, yeah,
I think his name was
Darren. Go with Darren.
Oh no, no no no no no no no!
He's gonna go shake my hand.
Darren is so cool, Zack.
You cannot mess this up.
But there's so many possible handshakes!
Like the traditional shake. The hand hug.
The code of honor. The slap 'n' grip.
The hug 'n' grip. The slide 'n' pound.
The dog pound. The pound to
explosion. And the high five.
But if I remember correctly,
he said he was from the
- East Coast.
- [Voiceover] Which means
there's a 79% chance
his preference of shake
is the slap 'n' grip.
So don't mess this up, Zack.
Oh wait! Oh no no no no no!
- You got a weak handshake, bro.
- It's not what it looks like, Darren.
- My name's Ben.
- Ben. Right, okay.
Have a good one, Ben! Next time, man!
You're from the East Coast, right?
(techno music)